كن مستعدا لكن لما لكل احتمال يرد
المتاهبون الكبار اذا لم تدخل للمناورات
العسكريه في تلك الخانه فهي في الغالب
حماله رسائل
ولعل منها منطلق مع صاروخ كروز فرد صوتي
من طراز موسكيت مضاد للسفن اختبره الروس
في بحر اليابان لم تكت تمضي 24 ساعه على
الاختبار حتى بدات القوات الاستراتيجيه
الصاروخيه الروسيه تدريبات تشمل انظمه
صواريخ يارس النوويه البالستيه العابره
للقارات
تقول موسكو ان التدريبات التي تجري في
منطقه نوفوسايبرسك التابعه للمنطقه
العسكريه الوسطى كانت مقرره سلفا ليس
واضحا اذا كان الامر مرتبطا باوكرانيا حيث
تدور ما يسميها الكرملين حربا هجينه مع
الدول الغربيه يتوقع ان يطول امدها
وهنا تؤكد روسيا اقتناعها بضروره الحيوله
دون الاصطدام مع دول نوويه مع انها توقفت
عن اشعار الولايات المتحده بشان انشطتها
النوويه بما في ذلك اختبار الاسلحه
وما يختبره الامريكيون هذه الايام هو قدره
حلفاء لهم في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادي على الصمود امام هجمات معاديه
محتمله هناك في اقصى جنوب شبه الجزيره
الكوريه المشحونه بالتوترات تجري الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه مناورات جويه
وبرمائيه انه الاستعداد كما يقول الجانبان
لاي هجوم قد يستهدف شبه الجزيره الكوريه
مخصص للدفاع عن شبه الجزيره الكوريه هو
مهم بالنسبه لنا وبالنسبه لاستقرار
المنطقه ككل
اكد كلامه سريعا بيان رسمي مشترك جدد
الالتزام بتقويه الروابط العسكريه
والامنيه بين واشنطن وسول من الشمال تراقب
تدريبات يقلقها انها تتوسع في تعزيز الرضع
وتشمل الاصول الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه على
مدى اسابيع تلاحقت الرسائل في الاتجاه
المعاكس
اطلاق صواريخ باليستيه واستعراض اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه بل ودعوه من قياده كوريا
الشماليه للاستعداد لشن هجمات نوويه في اي
لحظه